this table here we're going to talk
about all the different things we're
going to try and measure and give an
introduction to these units right the
first thing is you know is that
basically basically who got two types of
things we want to measure and then lots
of different sub ways of doing them and
I'm not to be too technical about it but
the two things we want to measure our
space and stuff okay how much space does
something take up and how much stuff can
you well I'll explain when you have a
look at the two different measures of
stuff okay so three measures of space
there are three because we live in we
inhabit a three dimensional world so we
like to measure things in three
dimensions okay the three measurements
are zero no they start with an L and a
enemy
we've got volume I heard another one
area and length now you gave them to me
in reverse reverse order I've put them
in this order because they correspond to
length is one dimension right that's why
you can use something straight it's a
line one dimension means you can only go
back and forth in one direction okay
whereas area is something which you need
a plane for right so that's two
dimensions you can have length for
example and with that's this way and
this way you can fill in what's volume
three dimensions okay so these are the
different ways that we can talk about
how much space and object takes up okay
now let's think about these units for a
second we have like we said them the
metric system when you're about
conversions shortly but what units do we
know about for measuring length okay
we've got let's actually put meters
we'll put it sort of in the middle okay
and on either side of that we've got
things that are smaller than that and
things that are bigger what will be
something a little bit smaller than a
meter centimeters okay so we'll go that
way and you can go smaller than
centimeters again right millimeters but
not only can you get smaller you can get
bigger we'd pretty much go to kilometers
I think those are all our common metric
units I have said common because there
are some other ones but there you know
for example these nanometers that's
getting even smaller but clearly for in
our context that's not as right now
here's the coffee one of the great
advantages of the metric system when you
are then going up from one dimension to
two dimensions you don't introduce a
whole new set of things for example you
might say I'm you guys started with do
you stop with meters you started meters
right so you'd say well now that in two
dimensions I'll talk about a square
meter right we take the same idea and if
you go one meter one meter like a square
literally okay that is what we call a
square meter and you can read that as
meters squared if you like but I prefer
to say square meters it's the same for
all the others right you've got square
centimeters
you've got square millimeters and I'm
gonna pause there because thinking about
this for a second the next thing up
based on the top of um based on the top
of our arm rows there would be
kilometers squared now a kilometer you
give a call huh
we'll go back up to my square over here
think of a kilometer and how big this
space is a square kilometer is a lot of
space okay so therefore because we
actually want sort of more useful
measures that are beautiful in that but
bigger than just a square meter which is
about this desk that I'm sitting at we
have something in between yeah that's
right we've got hectares this you don't
know at the um yeah H a is the
abbreviation we've got acres but that's
part of your puro system and then it's
been very well right so we'll talk about
we'll talk about acres later on I will
mention that you just out of curiosity
but you've got hectares in the middle
there does it or no how many square
beans there are in hectare there are
10,000 and where it comes from is see
this guy up here this square that I've
drawn that's what called it up by one
kilometer so if I wrote that in meters
what would that be that'll be a thousand
meters here and a thousand meters here
so where is ten thousand fit into this
it's going to be a hundred meters by
by a hundred meters you see that a
hundred times 100 that's four zeros
that's ten thousand yeah so a hundred
means biography is much easier to
picture a hectare that's a very very
useful sort of unit of measurement and
we use that in farms or in large
properties all the time okay so that's
why the hectare is and then after that
if you wanted something even bigger you
can have a square kilometer yes nine
acres we should do a conversion there
I'll talk about you know where we're
trying to get back and forth between
isn't it doesn't surprise me okay now
lastly for three dimensions again we're
taking the pattern we have cubic meters
we have cubic centimeters we have cubic
millimeters and pretty much in common
terms that's all you're really good
again like there's not really a measure
above that that gets used very very
frequently I mean you could talk about I
suppose cubic kilometers but then
massive right so like I said this is a
column for carbon things so that's where
I'm just gonna leave those okay now you
remember I said yeah it's kind of cool I
said we're about measuring space how
much space something takes off and we're
also about measuring stuff so there are
two things here that I wonder if you
know you've heard these words before
that are both measures of some kind of
stuff but different kinds of stuff right
so related to volume is capacity right
now capacity is a measure of how much
stuff can you fit inside a container
okay so how much fits inside so this is
kind of similar to I suppose you would
say internal volume okay now this is a
bit weird because volume capacity are
very very closely related they're both
about like you know three dimensions
yeah what kinds of units are related to
capacity yeah all right now we have to
be tuners which talk about like the
three dimensional theme but I'm gonna
leave that up here under volume if you
went and you bought a container
I've said liquid from you know you'd
measure that eared so here's some units
leaders what if we were smaller their
leaders okay which we were shortened as
Mills okay you can have ones that's more
than that but less common what would be
if you have saved senior parents that
water bill something it's going to be in
kilo liters okay so that's a small K so
you can see here all of these are
measures about how much stuff can I fit
it here and this is kind of like history
yeah
people started off measuring okay we've
been you know milking cows for a long
time so we have the same kind of
container how much can you put in there
that's called this Alito alright but the
people wanted to be able to make
containers that are gonna feel later in
this so you want to be able to measure
that out so that's why volume and
capacity kind of are approaching the
same problem three dimensions in from
different angles as it were okay
there is also the question where you can
only fit a certain amount of space stuff
inside something in the container is
much bigger but we'll talk about those
later on one more measure of stuff which
is mess okay so remember capacity is how
much fits inside verse is about how much
is it made of right like literally if
you were to take all of the atoms inside
this object
what stuff it's made of and you add it
all up I how much would you get right so
it's worth noting that mass doesn't
change if you're like in space for
example okay so you've got no weight in
space but you still the same mass that
you have if you down a lift or on the
surface of sand or whatever okay how we
measure mass okay so we'll talk about
kela grams what would be smaller than
kilograms grams what would be smaller
than grams milligrams okay because I'm
going from big to small big to small
No okay now interestingly and this is
probably a bit of an exception but I if
you had a million grams a million grams
right I using the prefixes that we're
about to talk about in this table down
below you would call that a mega gram
but we don't call them big rants we have
another name for them they called Todd's
okay so you're like oh wait a million
grams is the same as a thousand
kilograms right so a metric ton is the
next one up okay last one here and it's
a little bit weird so I'm going to put
it in a different color doesn't really
fit with all the rest of these but I
didn't want to have a table with just
one row so I do want to tell you one
non-metric measure but you guys are so
good I don't think it'll be that much of
an issue and the quantity that were
measuring here it's time right so is it
you know how long that's that's the
question that this answers and of course
we know that the units for these again
thinking about carbon units are going
from big to small we're going to go days
hours tell me what comes next minutes
and seconds okay so this is not metric
right it's not a decimal basis not base
10 unlike all the rest of it we've got
24 hours a day and 60 minutes in an hour
and 60 seconds in a minute by the way
does anyone know why they call minutes
and seconds minutes if you saw this word
with no context you would not know what
it meant
it'll be either minute or my new at
minut of course just means small right
so all the minute is is a small part of
an arrow like because it has a very long
time we want a finer measure than that
right so there why is this called a
second well it's because it's the second
minut division of time right
if there's another one I guess they'd
call the that that's got to get
confusing so anyway we're very we've
been using these since we were you know
able to talk so there you go that's why
they call that they're on